tre is in Big Spring Texas hey tre how
are you I'm good mr. Ramsey how are you
sir I am better than I deserve what's up
in your world
well first off let me tell you you're a
rockstar to me man I uh I grew up
idolizing Michael Jordan and you have
taken his place ha ha well I'm
considerably shorter I'll tell you that
I think you're probably better than with
your money than he is with his gobs of
money but I just really appreciate what
you do for all these hundreds of
thousands of listeners and it's it's
changed my life and hopefully will
continue to do so
well things that's just I look forward
to listening on the radio and reading
things that you and your daughter put
out and for what it's worth I really
appreciate it well thank you how can I
help today
ah I've read your book the Total Money
Makeover also smart money smart kids I
guess would be very easy to say that
that I'm a gazelle probably with Tiger
teeth if that's possible I I've been
wanting to get out of debt in a bad way
for for quite a while my wife and I are
not seeing eye to eye on the budget
we've we've uh we've actually sat down
and had three budget meetings uh for the
past six weeks I get paid twice a month
and uh bless her heart she's uh she's
gone along with it and she's uh I don't
know I just we just are not on the same
page mr. Ramsey and I don't know how old
are you I'm 37
I long you've been married for 14 years
okay and so what does it sound like when
you all are not in agreement it's it's
just always a battle of some sort
everyday is it everyday sir you do a
budget every day oh no no no no no so
she a member so are you when you when
you do a budget and you agree to it she
doesn't want to stick to what she agreed
to well she does but with a caveat she
is there's always kind of a you
so uh aside underhanded you know it's
just she's never happy with it is it's
always yeah it's okay but and you know I
like I said I started out how much debt
have you guys got well I've got $1,200
left on a car loan $10,000 credit card
and then $130,000 left on a mortgage and
what's your household income about a
hundred and thirty thousand okay and so
where is it that the budget is tightened
so tight that it's stealing her joy give
me an example category well like well
for instance today and then that's why I
made the decision to call you um her car
broke down and I had to get come get her
my truck which she hates to drive and
she just I took it to get repaired and
she's just fed up with the car that's
got 190,000 miles and I understand that
but she wants to go out and get a brand
new vehicle instead of you know I've got
emergency funds we've got emergency fund
set up just just for that much is in
your merchants II front right now is
$1,800 okay you make a hundred thousand
dollars a year right yes yes sir and you
you doesn't sound like you got much debt
left you ought to be done real soon
well that's just the thing is absolutely
but it's it's small things like that
there's always a nagging about we need
to do this and we need to do that and
everything is just pulling us towards
more you know another credit card or
another car payment and you know I
begged I begged her to listen to your to
your radio show I'm Victor to read the
book and have another point of view as
to want to do something rather than you
know your husband says so do it you know
what I mean so that yeah that doesn't
work and really Dave Ramsey said so do
it doesn't work what what she's not
getting is she's not getting why we're
doing this right and she understands
what we're doing but she don't
understand why and that's why she's
bringing no energy to the table because
she doesn't she doesn't grasp the why
yet and so you guys need to sit down and
back
from all this stuff and dream again and
go we make too much money to be this
broke what would it be like if we didn't
have any payments what would it be like
if we were here in here
and what would be like if we had a
hundred thousand dollars in the bank
what would it be like if you had a
decent car that we paid cash for instead
of an old beat-up hundred ninety
thousand dollar car and we sit making
$130,000 broke what would that be like I
want to pay a price to win for a pretty
time to get there and you know why is
just not big enough in this equation you
need to get get her to dream with you
and what is the thing that gets her
excited about the future if you weren't
broke what it'd feel like to have a
million dollars and what would we do if
we had a million dollars that kind of
stuff hold on I'm going to put you guys
through Financial Peace University as my
guest
you